[Music]
what are we gonna do today barry
we are gonna get
all up in the closure business
closures
closures and we're going to embrace them
and it's going to be great
all right well let's do it so let's
where what are we trying to accomplish
so you have
i guess four contacts you sent me some
code ahead of time um and we're like
here's where we're going today and i was
like cool and then i ate lunch
so
so
let's take a look at the server function
just so we can see this and then i'm
going to
we're going to kind of double uh what's
here so we're going to have two buttons
for rolling the dice and
we're going to try to
hide a lot of this logic so that we can
kind of say like from 23
to 38 that's like
roll a dice
and
that's it like we can just listen to
things and we can try to hide this away
and i think it's really useful when
you're trying to make your server
function not over a thousand lines
of code and it can actually be
maintainable and reusable but still use
expressions that shiny is like wanting
you to use
i think we'll kind of see it happen and
how it's kind of not easy to do unless
we use some closures
with arling so
let's
let's try to see on like
how like what would we need to do if we
were gonna have
uh two dice buttons and
uh roll the dice buttons and two
button outputs
let's kind of change the code um from
there right so you're saying we want
roll nice roll another dice yes
and then
you want
output for dice one and then an output
for dice too
sounds great okay
so i
would go to the ui that's usually my
so i would do something like
action button
and then typing out all my variable
names
let's make them consistent
i hope that all of the comments are
about how semantically like the grammar
of die versus dice
yes
truly what i hope for okay so we did
this thing here
why did i name that code like text that
is not a good name
all right so we're going to do this
dice02x
let's do
output
so2
uh
placeholder equals through and then i'm
actually going to make this a change
so that it's consistent but before we do
anything else let's get in here and
change
do i need to was there anything else
that no because i think we did
everything with reactive so i think
we're okay i don't think we're just 51
yeah
code like text
yeah
no yeah all right so we've added the ui
elements which we have
so we've got that we can't really tell
which one is which
um
that's okay
and
so now we need to hook them up because
if i roll this second dice
nothing but the first one should still
work
yeah we're good
there we go
[Music]
so if we were to
do this again
um
i think the like one of the easiest ways
like let's just walk through the 30
seconds of pain that this will be so
let's copy
33 to 48 because that's all the logic
that we need
um
if you want we can put it yeah right
right after 48 that works all right so
let's add some labels here just so i
remember what we're doing
so this is original code
one dice
and then
that's definitely not right but that's
okay
there we go
all right
and
we would also need let's duplicate 70
to 73
and have that
print to output dice 2.
okay all right i broke everything
yes
just kidding i mean well i mean i guess
we did with that code right so if we run
this
we've just duplicated which we expect
because we haven't changed any of our
inputs
yeah just duplicated our code the only
thing we've really changed is this
although we haven't hooked that up like
yes that's still hooked up but it's
hooked up to this so and so we also need
to then like 52 54 all of those
variables need to be renamed like last
roll two
dice val2
like
are we doing this
yeah yeah we're gonna go through it just
just to experience how not fun this is
so you're saying that my
my first approach to all of this
is actually wrong because this is 100
what i would do is come in and just let
me duplicate my code
it is not wrong it is just not efficient
um
so
it will work and that's great so that's
what we want
okay
um and then last roll
two
nope wait
no
yep
last roll two find event dice is it dice
val oh i'm already lost
nice fallow too and that dice vallo too
and then we'll just change 76 to dice
vallo too
and keep the other variables as they
were all right this should actually work
with both buttons
yeah
okay because we don't have to change
the values inside the function because
it's really
the label of this it's the label of the
reactive that we're accessing so we
could have every variable inside a
reactive
the same name but what's going to affect
it is the
this guy right here now we could
if we wanted to change like the max
number
we could change that here but we don't
want yes like if we had a different uh
number selector then maybe we do you
know select max number two but we're
both reading from the same max number so
um yeah and as i said with the reactive
um the variable like new role is scoped
to the
expression of 54
so
it will not leak out and so we don't
need to rename it
yeah so this works this is awesome
um yeah all right recording done good
[Music]
now what i've hit what if i said let's
do it for 10 buttons and 10 outputs like
now this just gets sticky and
it
it might work you know we could get
clever and how in like doing some square
brackets with a for loop and a couple
other things but
let's instead make a helper function and
i think that'll just kind of resolve
everything
okay
this will be a little bit of
a of a journey but in the end we'll come
out on the other end
of the tunnel here because it's kind of
like you need
you can't do it halfway it's all in so
i feel like a hobbit
yeah this is uh definitely a journey
outside of the chair
going on an adventure
yeah
um so
like how we were doing other things with
uh functions like oh we see duplicated
code let's make a function
let's just go ahead and do that and then
just kind of roll with this
all right so um
yeah i'll let you drive
okay
let's make a function what do we what
are we well what are we functionizing
like are we gonna take
everything are we gonna take 36 through
81 and functionalize all of that um
for this purpose let's not do the output
let's only do
like 36 to 52. okay so we're kind of
doing 36 through 50.
are going to function eye
one dice roll
[Music]
um
that's not right yes
yeah and we wouldn't need the return
yeah yeah perfect um and then i just
personally just go ahead and copy 40 to
56 and put it in and then we adjust it
from there okay
so one way that we could get around this
without doing closures and things
because we know exactly what we're doing
um
just as an example is we could pass in
like a key
um like a button key and
a
max number key would be a nice one
so just for fun let's go ahead and go
down that route
and say like um yeah like button key and
max number key
and we'll default max number key to
equal
quote
select max number like the name there
awesome
and then let's go ahead and use these uh
like key values so
99 time we do things uh we're accessing
input values via the dollar but you can
also access them
via bracket bracket
a square bracket square bracket so let's
update 40 and 42
to listen to the max number key variable
so it'll be like input bracket bracket
max number key
okay
great
and we can do this again
uh down there
oops no autocomplete got me good
uh
and the reason we're doing double
brackets is because single brackets will
only return these return a single item
whereas if there's more than one item
the single brackets will return all of
those items
yes yes single brackets returns a subset
list and double brackets returns the
value for the key value of the list yep
really this is our power is that i use
big amorphous hand wavy terms and then
you're like yes the technical vocabulary
that you're trying to use is
yes
but it's it's good right if you want
multiple you do single if you only want
single item you do so we're selecting a
single value which we've already set
here to our select max number so our max
number
is this guy right here
and so that's like saying 13 equals max
number key yeah we are we're good this
looks great
i'm following
okay
let's do the same treatment to 46 with
button one
so that'll be input of button key
and do we need to change
button key to
no because if we want to generalize that
and we've got two buttons
yeah so we'll we'll go ahead and leave
it empty meaning like that's required um
if you wanted you could give it a
default value like for yourself just
that way you can run things faster
but i think it's good as is
all right
so
let's go ahead and use our function so
let's just look at the the functions
right now
last roll is scoped great
we then
do a reactive where we listen to some
max number
and we make sure that it's a new number
compared to last roll on 41
and then we return that new number
but that reactivity won't run
until we have a button press which so we
found that event great
and then we update
the last roll given the dice value
whenever the dice value changes
cool
um
this is that's like we could just
yeah yeah um
that works but it does need to be the
last thing in the function at least
so okay cool this is good and we can
actually have multiple calls to one dice
roll and we don't need to rename the
variables internally like they'll all
just be constant which is awesome
so let's actually see if we can
change the code below to use this method
ah okay so
we theoretically shouldn't need another
last roll
and then
all right so
dice val so this is all wrapped in a
function here
so this is
theoretically
let's see is this the same i feel like
this is the same code
but just not in a function
and so
here
i feel like if i wanted to rewrite this
i would do something where
i would do like one dice roll and then
my argument would be button
01
and then i think i can leave max number
key as it is because that's already
going back to the ui element here
it seems fair
seems fair i never know if i'm walking
into a trap with you
i can't remember what the render text
had can we look at that method at the
bottom
down here
oh it was using diceval so we actually
had um
so we uh
yeah so the dice it has die style which
actually didn't use last roll but we
used
last roll as a placeholder
ah what we really wanted is dice valve
so the 54 should be dice val not last
roll that is my fault
that's all right
all right awesome learning
so we're going to do one dice
roll and then my button key
is going to be okay let me think about
this because the input is already
accounted for in my function
i only need to provide the button key
which is going to be button01
oh in quote c
and then
i don't need to provide the max value
because that's already a default right
all right
so this is the
dice roll
button one and then i'm assuming
i could do one dice roll for button two
uh yep
all right
and
um
yeah keep going
let me i can let me just clean some
things up here
and then i think i can get rid of
my second dice here so the last row two
these guys
[Music]
yeah from there
all right because then we've got the
output
so
i'm assuming would the next step be
[Music]
i'll put dice a one
okay what is
what are we doing should we check our
app what are the next best steps
so you have die style and dye style o2
um so one dice roll returns a reactive
so we should store that to like dice val
and dice fallow 2.
that one's the label there on 54 is good
but we need to store the the result of
58 into a
a variable
got it so
[Music]
and for fun we can say dicevalo1
and
and then we'll update 65 to be dice
file01
this should work
kind of exciting
okay we have a history here
of famous last words
all right let's see let's see what
happens let's set that to 20.
all right so that's working as expected
boom
our code is already a little bit
more efficient so we have
functionality function functionalized
functionalized that's a word now we have
functionalized a dice roll
all of our reactives and now
we've got an output
perfect
[Music]
okay are you telling me we can make it
more efficient
i think well make it more
uh
user-friendly is is kind of where it is
so i like this this answer isn't bad um
it's a
good stepping stone
um
i
you know i would expect most people to
be able to create this function and to
execute this function
this
where we're going to go next is
a little bit more into the arlang
into
uh closures into
expressions and things that don't make
sense right away but they're super
powerful
um but that's the r language we are
choosing our pain now
uh we are choosing the user benefits yes
[Music]
but we've done a lot of the heavy
lifting already like we already have a
function that's there
it's just i like
58 when we look at it's like one dice
roll of quote but no one
i now have to remember that that
represents input dollar but no one like
that's a little
much where normally we're used to
writing like reactive input dollar
button 01. like that's more familiar for
me
um so
yeah i think i think it'll work let's go
let's do some closures let's embrace the
closure fun closures um
so a little bit of safeguarding
um let's actually
um make a reactive between 37 and 39
that is
like max like uh
yeah like max
max number or something like that
is the reactive
of a not not reactive i'll just plain
reactive of
and then we'll just do
our input max number key
okay
awesome and then we'll replace input max
number key in 44 and 46 with max number
oh okay 44 and 46.
uh
so while you're doing that there is no
computational like
speed up by
um like input dollar whatever is is a
constant static value so like calling it
twice isn't a big deal uh reactives do
we have this like soft caching built in
where like we don't recalculate
everything twice so they're kind of
equivalent but it gives you a little bit
more freedom down the road from where
we're going with this code 4446 max
number need to execute because we need
to retrieve the max number value
awesome great so let's test this just to
make sure this works
and then we can click button click
button awesome
great
okay
so
closures um let's look at
i really like this
max number thing here in 39 and 40 to
41. i think this is like a very isolated
quick
and easy thing to do um
let's also add
um
something like
um
in the function up at the top
let's add like instead of max number key
um
maybe we say like max number expression
okay
and i don't know if you wanna um
uh
yeah um let's do like just exper max
number expert
great
and let's go ahead and get rid of the
default value
um because that is
not what we want oh let's change our
function call down below of one dice
roll
and have um
done
beneath uh sorry like in 60s 70s
wherever that's at yeah great 60s
um
let's say the max number expert equals
input dollar
uh
what is it select max number or
something
where what
oh sorry i'm not not talking well here
uh
i feel like
you've like i'm contagious and now
you're talking like me
uh so what did what was the code that we
had before when we wanted to retrieve
the max number what was that code it was
something like input dollar yeah it was
input dollar
select underscore max
underscore
great let's put that there in the like
the second argument okay function
so you're saying input and then we'll do
um
i literally just sent it uh select max
yeah and we can do dollar select max
number
um
because we're using it directly right
[Music]
so
like
this work it's interesting like if we
were to look at this as a function
we could be
like if i'm interpreting this as as is
right now what this would do is it would
take the max number value
right now and it would never update and
it would never listen to anything if it
was just a static value we would say oh
the max number is zero and we move on
and it'll never hit any reactivity like
this is how normal functions
would operate
but what we want is we want to have this
expression
be used at a later date and to allow
shiny to re-execute that reactivity over
and over and over again and i think this
is just like
really neat things um so let's move back
up to the reactive
um yeah the max number reactive and we
now have the max number expert
cool
so
if we were to let's go ahead and
duplicate 39 to 41 so that we have what
we had before
and then uh this is our new stuff
so
like natural tendency right away is to
go ahead and let's say let's replace
input bracket bracket max number key
with our expression so max number expert
right so to do
that
uh no just the whole line because the
max number expert equaled input dollar
select max number right
so we're just kind of
swapping it in
and
now
we're kind of looking at it it's like
okay so we have a reactive and it's
saying
like retrieve the value of max number
expert well
if i have the value it's not really a
reactive expression
because if it's a function right at the
the
reactivity is cut immediately
uh typically and you just receive the
value and
nothing is gonna work as you want and
that stinks
um
so this is where um
we are wanting uh there's a thing in in
uh
arling closures do you think it would
help if we pulled up the docks is that
easy to
find the dots are you there all right so
we are in the docks we've got some meta
programming patterns and we've got a
little bit of injection
i see some of our favorite words here um
i think most people
who are app developers are familiar with
dplyr
and there's this wonderful
problem with um
or not problem but situation that occurs
with uh d player in that
what if you want i don't like d player
does this uh like um delayed or was it
not delayed i can't remember the name
metaprogramming right so
because you have
the ability to ask for column names
directly
what if you want a variable to represent
a column name that you're asking for
directly
and this gets a little difficult like
either you have to subset from your your
calling data frame which is not what we
want to do
um and so they have uh
uh with arling we we're now able to do
this using like these uh forwarding
patterns
such as diffusing and injecting
and uh i am very familiar with the uh
it's called the bang bang operator or
exclamation point exclamation point
uh paired with endquo
because i like to handle these
expressions
uh very directly so end quo i would grab
it and then i would replace the value
using bang
bang
and
that is how i'm familiar with it but
if all you do is you immediately do a
bang bang end quote and that's all you
do with the variable then you can use
these double curly brackets
and these double curly brackets is
embraces or embracing and it's just a
shorthand version of bang bang and coil
so we're going to steal this
and use it within um
within shiny within our function all
right recently uh reactive
uh
and a few and observe and a few other
methods uh
gain support for closures
and so now we can use these forwardings
and embracing and whatnot
let's do it
so
just embrace everything right like just
yeah uh
so
uh what i like to do at the very
beginning of the function is to
end quote all the expressions that i
don't want to evaluate now but i want to
evaluate at a later time
promises
say again are we creating promises
um
in
according to the our package promises no
we are not
but closures do feel like a promise to
evaluate something
but it kind of grabs the expression and
the environment where that expression
came from
and then you can pass it along the both
of them which usually somewhere along
the way
in the olden times if one of them would
get lost and
not a good thing when that occurs
enclosures bundle it up into one and
make everything much better
so let's um go ahead and after 35 we'll
say max number quo
equals
endqo
of max number expert so max number quo
i'm gonna do a brand new one
yeah max uh yeah a brand new variable
name yep max number quo
and will be the end quo
um
end of max number expert
so
endquo is a method that will turn
your argument name into a closure it is
specifically meant to be called inside a
function
if i was just in a script i might just
use quo
but inside a function it's end quo okay
putting max number expert in its own
little environment and just saying go
sit on the shelf over here
yes and it won't evaluate it so it's
right there
but it's all bundled up on the shelf yep
it's for like later it's like a little
bit before your birthday
there's no death points okay
and then
yes and uh
let's go down to 46. okay
so
46 um
reactive is also something that's
expecting an expression
so it's not something that we could even
change it to max number quo and it would
work because
we're we still have this issue of like
reactive will just execute the
expression
that is there which is saying like
retrieve max number expert and that's
not what we want we want it to actually
it's very subtle but we want it to
execute the closure or execute the
closure expression is what we want
so to tell reactive that i want you to
use the contents of this variable and
not
the text representation of this variable
we will use
inject with bang bang
um and the inject will go outside the
reactive
um
bang bang will stay there
it's it's the way i described it
so you're saying inject the reactive
so we're
yep and then let's go ahead and take the
curlies off of uh
of there just to help us
think that i'm now injecting the
expression so i'm not
giving an expression i'm injecting an
expression
but it's not the expert will do the quo
the maximum quo
and the bang bang is like unwrapping our
present
is yeah it's unwrapping the present but
not evaluating it yet
so it's like a cool toy that we've
unwrapped but cannot yet touch
uh yeah i i think uh to kind of go with
this present is um end quo put it in a
shipping box okay and it's shipped to us
and now it's unwrapped and it's
available for reactive to to use okay
um and inject
put it in there like it snuck it in
so
let's go ahead and comment 4244 and i
think this and
uh
did we
replace max number expert in both
locations down below
um in the one dice roll calls
awesome yeah
so i think i think this will work
no
oh no
all right let's
library arlington
you know the number of times that this
has gotten me lately is kind of
surprising
all right are you ready
all right let's see what happens
that number
okay look at that
sweet
that's a really weird dice that would
have to be a
that's a good spring teaser how large
would this dice not have to be like it
would have to be massive to have that
many sides
be like rolled adam
so let's let's go down to
our function calls that we that we're
making
so it works right yeah um
and it's i think it's a lot more
representative of what's happening so
the user is saying here's my reactive
select max number
um
let's actually uh change this a little
bit just to show that this is an
expression that's being done
so for die style one let's go ahead and
put it in curlies
and say
uh
just the input select max number just
that part oh okay
and uh oh single curly
i know i just got really excited
can't embrace yet
um so let's do select max number plus
five or something like that
okay uh something bigger and then let's
rerun the app and we should get
the first dice should have values up to
eight
okay secondary should only have values
up to three
so we've got seven
i just want to see if we can hit eight i
mean we might not loss of probability et
cetera et cetera oh there we go
and then this will only be one to three
yeah look at that we did a little
low math with our expression
and so this now gives the the caller
much more freedom as to what they want
to do or things like that and the
function logic is all hidden away we can
put it in the r folder we could you know
source it from somewhere else maybe a
different package
but this one dice roll is now available
yeah
i like it
so let's actually do the same treatment
with the button expression okay this guy
yeah so instead of
button one um
it we should turn it into something like
uh
input dollar button 01.
okay
yep
and same with 71. you want to do both
here let's do both all right
great
and one dice roll
um let's see that at the top
so that's button key so let's turn that
into button expert
and
after 38 we will end quote button expert
and store it as button quo
i like just end quoting everything at
the top that way you know you know
what's available
and then
uh yep we can delete that and our button
quo can be
injected
in
53
53 is where we're going okay so
we could just do
instead of so it would be bind events
injects
bang bang button quote
and
inject has to go outside the bind event
it's never going to happen for me
yeah it's a little little off and then
to throw in a little more wrinkles uh
the pipe operator from 52
is actually we want it to be for the
bind event the internal parameter not
for the inject so we should pipe to a
curly bracket
and uh that way
yep and then so now this is a magritter
expression
and so we can bind event to dot comma
bang bang button coil
dot comma yeah so the dot represents
whatever was passed into 53
yeah that that reactive and this should
work
so reload app hopefully it doesn't break
it did not all right so
the first one should still go up to
eight
great much more than three saw a couple
fives in there
great
perfect all right we did it we did the
thing
[Music]
this like it to me this is a like a big
journey but then the possibilities you
just unlocked everything
like now the the user can be like oh i
want to be a button and something else
or i want it to be
a list of things or
there's all sort like i can now as a
user provide many things for this
expression
and not just a single key and be very
limited
to uh input dollar or input bracket
bracket yeah so you've expanded the
scope of what
can be done with this same amount of
code like you would add other features
would require more code but not
necessarily more calculations
correct absolutely
um
so
uh the
the joke comes full circle let's embrace
it um
uh yeah
we are only using the expressions in one
location and we are only
uh
we end quote and we
call bang bang
so let's use the embrace operator
instead and then we can just kind of get
rid of the intermediate
operations
so
get rid of these
yep
all right and now
do i still need inject or is inject
handled by my double curlies
uh you still need inject um the double
curly is going to be the replacement for
the bang bang and the end quote call
so
whoops no
yeah so the embrace operator is a double
curly similar to the bang bang it
you know it's something that arleng
looks for and has overwritten and
max number quo doesn't exist anymore so
it needs to be max number expert
what it originally represented
great then here
i'm gonna do this guy and it's button
and then
do it again
[Music]
nice
i think the formatting is to put his
face but i'm not entirely sure so we're
just going to go with it it's fine i
like it
it's clear it's very clear that
something
is happening it kind of calls your
attention to it like something's
happening that's maybe not what i expect
yes unless you do this all the time in
which case
you expect
even then
even then i think this will work um
let's run it
all right let's see
i have a six we got an eight yep looks
like everything there is working
i'm gonna i'm gonna actually jinx us and
say i don't think we've ever had a
session where
the app has run so smoothly each time
yes uh it's also super helpful having a
working app to start with
this is true
so we were altering a good app versus
creating it from scratch that's true
that's true all right so are we like is
this is this it are we now
checkbox done can we make this more
efficient or is this kind of that's
that's it that's that's the journey
all right we made it i don't i don't
know the hobbit story very well so we
like went out and then we came back
right like they make it back
yeah they they make it back uh luckily
we didn't have to pit stop at mordor and
restart everything
[Music]
if we have a minute or two let's go
ahead and add react vlog so we can see
hear it happening all right
it's i mean it's it's one of my packages
i gotta i gotta promote it who made
react log barrett
uh this wonderful developer name's
barrett
um yeah so let's do um two parts so
uh we have a we did a library up top
right
and let's i like i mean for developing
purposes let's go ahead after 31 say
react log module ui
and we'll also do something near 35 as
well so it's all good that's right
right because you put it in both places
yeah so we need a uh basically an iframe
into the react log so it's react log
colon colon
um
react log
not installed
no it is i just did it there we go um
module ui and the fourth one there great
and defaults are good if you're only
using one so that's good
and then just inside the server i like
to enable react log
so react log uh
colon react log under
module under server
great
and things should line up with defaults
that's awesome
so let's go ahead and reload the app so
we can see all the reactivity that's
happening i'm making this larger for a
reason
oh um and we need to enable react log at
the beginning
so
yeah like after line four we can say
react log uh colon cone react log enable
oh just that
uh react log under enable
[Music]
yeah and that does all the settings for
you so that way it's just ready to go
all right
let's look at this
gorgeous little app react log here
so this is we have done nothing
and this is what we've got
let's go ahead and actually click each
button once
and then up up top uh you might have to
go to the side your face is in the way
ah
yeah so let's click the roll dice roll
second dice
and then um
let's refresh now uh the orange refresh
yeah
there we go a little bit more going on
look at all the steps
step 27
yeah all we did was check two buttons
and the 27 is actually
what it took to get to an idle state so
this isn't actually even where we
finished at
um so
this is right before you clicked the
first button and then the second button
so let's actually um
step through um with that arrow yeah and
we can just click a couple times so we
click button one it's now invalidating
everything downstream
cool
then the dice rolls trying to
update
from the bind event is listening getting
the max number that was selected
things are updating
great
we're now uh going through on the
execution of it
and then
good
that was one that was what happened with
the first button click yeah
uh oh and then the output of the dice
value is also updated and now the first
button click is done okay
similar thing will happen again with
second button click so it'll be this the
group below
oh so we're seeing the exact same thing
but what's really cool
to me is things like
it's using input button too
even though that was the expression that
we had in the function that was passed
through
to the reactive or
like those different things that we were
done
uh or were passed through so
i think it's it's nice to see how that's
occurring um
what's a little funny to see is diceval
is just hanging out nothing's connected
to it
you know why what is what's happening
here
so that is actually uh
that reactive is we can't
alter the reactive in place because it's
um
uh something that is
not uh
like you can't you can't alter the the
variable in place safely so when a
reactive is sent to bind event a new
reactive is created
and so that's why in the middle there's
a bind event of dice val
to input button
you can't see the full name
but to input button two and to input
button one if you go to the one above
so that actually replaced dice file
um
i think it's pretty neat to see
that that's what's occurring underneath
the hood
because you did create the re the dice
valve reactive but we tossed it away
when we
when we called bind event
[Music]
you